[Music]
[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sock young
very excited to be talking about all
things manifesting dreams using
actionable neuroscience very excited to
have Daria it's finger joining us on the
show hello hi Alan thanks for having me
thank you for coming on I'm super
excited yeah I love your work so much I
love how inspirational you are I love
your story as well and we're gonna be
unpacking that and these actionable
steps in this episode very pumped let's
give a background on Daria for those
that don't know the links in the bio to
her website Daria Sanger comm there you
can find more of her work as both a
brain power speaker as well as a mental
health advocate a social entrepreneur
and a social community builder and it's
more of these actionable steps and we'll
be talking about the dream sprint that's
going on where you can get involved in
following these actionable steps so as
we like to start our episodes with a
very big history perspective on things
all right humans find themselves now as
stewards of Earth after a long period of
evolution and here we are in the
exponential technology age what is your
current synthesis on the state of
humanity I think we are about to pivot
and we have this interest in time when
we have lots of power and we can decide
where we want to shift and I really
believe that nowadays gives us this
immense energy and that whatever you put
out this is multiplied and if you put
out something that you don't want to but
you kind of still putting this out even
unconsciously this will be multiplied
that's why I think we see this contrasts
off enormous suffering and like enormous
success and happiness and transformation
because and I don't think that there is
some people who should be playing for
that or something it's just there is
lack of awareness on how this works so
if more people will be given tools I
think will be like more happy humanity
yeah my take that's so good because it
is such a lack of awareness like you
said of knowing how to have these
actionable steps in manifesting our
dreams and what we want out of life in
the short time window that we have here
now
I want to follow up with that and ask
what would you say then is a key for us
to understand that awareness that we
have you mean what is the key like what
is the actionable step that you can do
to start to be awakened yes lots of ways
actually lots of ways every single
spiritual learning and every single
religion all of them basically talk
about one thing and this one thing
narrows down is to shift inside look
inside yourself search inside yourself
and then you find but for me it's not so
inspiring like I was not inspired by the
concept search inside myself because I
was a quote for and when I searched and
I didn't find anything I felt frustrated
and then I felt guilty that I didn't
find it so I think the first actionable
step is just to be honest with yourself
and to be non-judgmental with yourself
so the first step I think is acceptance
of how things are real acceptance when
you can just name name things you know
because for example in psychology when
you talk to when you
talk to people and you kind of like
experience in a conflict the first thing
to do to live it this context is to name
the emotions that people experiencing so
if we can do the same for ourselves name
what we are experiencing and by naming
will rarely acknowledge in them I think
that's very powerful and this is pretty
actionable because sometimes when you're
just feeling over well
oh you know sadness and depression and
all this stuff is real you just can go
down feeling guilty about feeling that
but if you catch yourself on the
acknowledgment I'm this I'm sad I'm like
mad I'm angry you can just be with that
without feeling guilty of feeling this
specific thing so yeah interesting
interesting okay so there's a couple
things here two things the first thing I
want to say is this what what you just
mentioned at the end which was this sort
of disagree knowledge meant of how I'm
feeling and then to as I as I looked
inside and I'd aim to look at myself
better in the mirror and try and and see
what I want to set as goals in my life
and I want to get there if I'm feeling a
certain way I'm acknowledging that I
feel that way that this sort of
reflective process is what can get us
tuned in better inside and then the
other thing that you mentioned the very
beginning was with your own story when
you looked in and you were like what I
don't see like yeah what I supposed to
see tell us about that yeah so you know
I I'm this person who can say that like
you she meditates but I actually do not
and it was complicated because like the
community where I'm in everybody
meditates and I was thinking like oh I
should probably do this - it's like the
up level of human being
and then I started to doing that and
then I I didn't find anything literally
it was boring it was frustrating and
then I was reading articles where people
were talking about oh yeah this is born
and frustrating but then you get results
and I didn't and I was saying okay and
I'm all about acknowledgement so I
acknowledge that and I felt maybe it's
just not the right time maybe it's not
the right tool for me because meditation
just one tool and we are all different
and sometimes it doesn't resonate and it
just means that there are other tools
out there that can be helpful for you so
I'm not saying that meditation doesn't
work I'm sure that it works because I
have so many people who do it and they
get awesome results and they feel better
and they heart harvest so those nice
things but it didn't work for me it
doesn't work for me the job yeah I
wanted to just say that too because
we've talked to Iran about that as well
and there have been plenty other people
as well that have mentioned this before
that that there are other tools for
people for their own self actualization
meditation is one of them that can help
in a bunch of ways that is thousands of
years old there are other sorts of
spiritual active actualization
techniques drugs drugs this is like the
shortest the shortcut is the old self
actualization techniques is psychedelics
I think so yeah I never tried I can't
say anything but maybe I will I don't
have it like in my you know to-do list
for tomorrow but I think there is
something in there definitely we can add
it to your to-do list you know we have
some upstairs maybe the person like
growing up in Russia I used I've never
seen like I don't know it's just not a
thing
it can see dirt very bad so and I'm also
tracking what kind of social influence
I'm getting from different societies
where I was I was living in Asia for
half a year in Vietnam so and in Russia
and then here and every single country
gives its own polarity yeah and right
now of course with every single new
exposure the mindset expands and now I'm
thinking that you know whatever works
yeah I think so too the newest tools
some of the old tools are emerging back
some of the new tools are being
developed the way that we can actually
map the brain with really high fidelity
and see what's going on on the on the
electrical and neurotransmission level
and then being able to to do things like
read out what exactly we are striving to
do and make actionable steps towards
that towards doing that that's a very
you know new sort of age way of doing
things on psychedelics is a little bit
on the older side as well so okay so
then how do we how do we how do we mesh
the meditation in the psychedelics and
these actionable insights from
neuroscience all these different tools
like you were saying all these different
paths up to self-actualization you're
like analyzing them what has been your
analysis of all of the different ones
and different ones work for different
people yeah yeah so so first takeaway is
that you should find your the tool for
you and you can do that by first trying
then asking other people and I think the
main thing is not to fall into the guilt
trap that if something did work for like
your friend and it didn't work for you
it doesn't mean something wrong with you
just means that it's not like you know
we all different height for example yeah
like I'm kind of like on the smaller
side the shorter side of people and if I
would you know try Clovis for like tall
people they won't fit me not because
something wrong with me because I just I
fall in another size category
and so probably if I would go to the
store which carry my size it would I
would be happier rather than trying to
fit in into like big ones so this is the
analogy that but I really I think that
are who resonate with it just you know
and all this dietary preferences we have
so many people with like gluten
intolerance s and then people who just
drink dairy and it bread all the time
and they feel perfect and it doesn't
mean that you should all do this so all
do that there is no polarity actually
this is just you pick the best for you
from everything and then you assemble
your perfect image and this perfect
image serves you for the best purpose in
your life so this is a really good
analogy this not you this do does not
not not walking into a store for babies
clothing yeah this is this is a good one
bactine do have the perfect okay yeah
yeah because then that's a tool so then
the different stores are different tools
for you to go and try the clothes on not
trying clothes too big not try and
clothes too small too tight too big yeah
yeah maybe you want really colorful
clothes maybe you want more like black
and white style clothes so interesting
and what are these different tools you
know you listen meditation psychedelics
there's nurses use these new actionable
steps in neuroscience like things like
future authoring like I have to write my
goals in 2019 for me to actually be able
to achieve goals in the year you have to
actually write things down and make
short-term steps to do them so like yeah
tell us about these different store
options the options start options yeah I
like options what I found out that tools
there are so many tools like every
single book you read there are different
tools that authors advise you to use but
in terms of all tools can be narrowed
down in different buckets for example
the bucket of sitting quiet and it can
be lots of tools like visualization
meditation body scans all of that so
from tools of sitting quiet you can pick
one because sitting quiet with different
purposes it can serve you but you should
just speak your format that's why I like
when you do when you go on the
meditation app you can browse through
different modalities and there are like
endless amounts of you know meditation
you can chant the mantra you can just
focus on something you can do like
divergent focus meditation you can do
kind of like the inner focus meditation
and some methods should resonate so this
is the first bucket the second bucket is
kind of like right down bucket the right
down bucket you can take tons of Chameli
exercises and you know some P some
people have more developed like visual
cortex and then kinesthetics cortex
olfactory of how to you oh yeah
olfactory and stuff like that so it just
depends what is your perfect way of
receiving information and also
expressing this information so in the
right hand bucket you can do a variety
of journaling and kind of like self
exploration exercises which I really
love for example in the program in the
trim sprint that I'm leading I give
people so how I built it I just its
whatsup message-based so every three
days you'll receive a whatsapp message
from me audio message like 15 minute
long where I'll explain some
neuroscience research about for example
topic like limiting beliefs or like
negative self-talk but baking with the
real stuff how brain works and then I
give you an exercise it's only exercise
on how to mentally clean this stuff and
then you have 72 hours to complete this
ascend it to me if you send it to me and
go further if you miss a deadline I
delete you from participation
so this is the yeah the write down stuff
for me is is huge because this is how
you can self-therapy yourself this is
your community building again with this
process because they have they have to
complete these goals in the dream sprint
that you send and I like this one with
with the known like things like no
negative self-talk ur catching yourself
as you are doing negative self-talk and
showing how it's backed by neuroscience
and it kind of just makes it's like
common sense like I'm not gonna sit
there and dwell in misery and negativity
I'm going to figure out K how is this
making me feel okay how can I get
through this feeling well I should
probably write down like what I want to
do and how I want to get it done and go
and do it stand up go for a walk etc you
started listing i like how you started
listing both the writing and yeah you
what did you call them bucket buckets
yeah so there's a but there's bucket
sitting still and then yeah there's tons
of different ways to sit still
yeah the most important key to not
sitting to not when you sit still is to
not have this with you put this on site
turn it off and have it away from you
and then just come and sit in a chair in
a room then just look just look or just
stay quiet close your eyes fuel your
body there's so many different ways like
modality such buckets and modalities I
like this and then there's the bucket of
writing and a bunch of different
modalities for goal-setting or for yeah
long-term vision short-term vision the
gratitude journaling all these different
yeah all this tools and you know you
also find the right there I think for
you yeah because you're finding the
right clothes for you the right from the
stores stores yeah you're trying on the
different modalities in the different
buckets you trying them on and you know
and also like in this if we think this
way acknowledgement is also the main
part because before we acknowledge that
before I acknowledge that I'm short
I can't understand which store should I
go to
I will go to different stores and be
like upset and irritated this doesn't
work but when I acknowledge that like ok
yeah I promptly short and it probably
like blonde so probably like my skin
color like isn't a lighter side so
probably this type of fabric said good
so you know you can kind of like
conclude so many stuff when you just
acknowledge something like when you are
angry maybe it's not the perfect time to
you know call off the person if you are
angry with maybe it's just a call that
you are angry and then you understand
that actually the strong emotion it
blasts biologically only for 40 seconds
and when forty seconds done you can
actually reason yourself out but if you
act during those 40 seconds you'll
regret it because it will be just a
bunch of biological reactions very
primal you know very like the reptilian
brain type of reactions you just eat
everybody you don't think so we want
ourselves not to go this way because we
have this amazing prefrontal cortex that
it's huge it it gives us all this
reasoning power and we should use it
it's like it's there for a reason
this is acknowledging our brain power
yeah this is teaching our other adults
and children around the world that we
have power to slow down and be with
feelings and then think and reason our
way through these primal feelings that
make sometimes cause like you've taught
as well these drastic rises in cortisol
levels which literally kill us over and
over time and we don't want to be a
slave to these thought processes that
are also they cast a negative aura they
cast a negative aura around us two other
P
low vibration vibration lows and then
you attract the same yeah that's yeah
you know versus versus when you're
walking around more with the smile
expressing gratitude to people all of a
sudden you're seeing more positive
things there you know that's it
yeah it's a huge difference in the way
that you can evolve okay this is this is
also you you were you know as you were
as you're teaching about this I'm
thinking like what you know you did what
was it you did caught it was cognitive
neuroscience at Stanford for a year
right yeah not for a year for four
months for four months there was a four
month program
what were the things that you learned in
that four-month program around these now
these dream Sprint's yeah yes yeah yeah
so I pick I pick stuff from different
programs that I've attended I've
attended sub programs with like dr. Joe
Dispenza it was like in person he's
laughs he's good because he's on the
edge of like almost pseudoscience and
real science and you know you can't
Excel the real science without assuming
you know without assuming that there is
something more to that which becomes
pseudoscience for a real science world
yeah so the main thing that really stuck
with me from the cognitive neuroscience
course at Stanford is that our memories
fake and it's not pseudoscience you know
before I knew I've heard Oh a number is
fake and we have fake memories but I was
putting it into the bucket of like mr.
sayers manic as a thorax but it's the
real thing that people study it by real
universities that there is dr. Elizabeth
Loftus and her research is all about
false memories how we form for false
memories how we fall into the trap of
believing them
and that's interesting it is very
interesting yeah and it's very real well
where do they come from you mean what
they come from Oh false memories where
do they come from yeah yeah that's
that's a great question so in most cases
they come from our tendencies to assume
the likely outcome or and sometimes this
likely outcome it's not positive or
negative it's just something that we
want to be you know for example a
post-traumatic stress disorder so many
things can adapt to the traumatic
situation that were never there but you
were so attached that your emotions were
so so strong that you add up things on
purpose and actually every time we
recall any memory we change at ten
percent every time we recall a memory
change at ten percent
so all this research is used for
interrogation processes in like federal
agencies because all of that is real and
interrogation processes when you
retrieve a memory yes and it's pretty
important that this memory is not false
totally so they follow the process that
allows them to do like the minimum of
alterations yeah you know to inspire
minimum alterations yeah cuz we were
they want they want you to be able to
recall in high fidelity yeah yeah I
can't
and the interrogation process can't you
also do reverse effects even though they
want the truth can't they also get you
to confess something
well sure that doesn't that happen as
well I would think that would be more
common than an interrogation proper to
trying to get the truth out of someone
they just want a confession and they
don't care how they get it yeah yeah I
think that's
I love conspiracy theories so I love you
too
because some of them are true that's why
Russia that's what people talk about
like we have conspiracy theory on every
single you know really layer of life
certain yeah yeah for sure
what's what's thing what's what some of
the most common ones like about like how
the ass wants to like undermine all
countries to I create 3/4 were like
countries like for example African
countries just Venezuela what is
happening right now in Venezuela the
United States of America is undermining
what's happening there they want a coup
to put in there a puppet president as
opposed to their current democratically
elected president no isn't that that's
not a conspiracy that's this is true the
United States of America is Empire the
same thing that we've always fought in
the history of time the United States of
America has become when we fought
against the British to achieve our
independence we became that same entity
yeah yes and that's not a conspiracy
that's that's true that's that is a
human condition yeah I think it's just
the light form for me to say that
something to put into the bucket of
conspiracy because we go conspiracy
that's their true sometimes like there
is a high likelihood that they are true
but they're called conspiracies because
they're not officially recognized true
so that's there's a lie against it they
call them conspiracies because they want
to maintain a lie yeah yeah the truth of
who we are as a species is a conspiracy
that we have to accept it's between God
and the devil and we need to get in line
and pay our taxes and mind our business
actually I've heard I got spirits around
that too
there is like a Darwin theory yeah that
we are kind of like evolution in from
the monkeys or Apes like whatever anyone
like from fish like what I'm not being
for billions of years
yeah for sure over billions of years but
also there is like conspiracy thing that
this monkey thing was kind of like
created on purpose for humans to feel oh
we kind of like fall into the monkey
side of things so it's a different
understanding rather than for example I
really like the theory it's called
panspermia I don't know yeah that's
right yes yeah I really like receipted
from another place you like yeah that
that just you know the planet was
populated and sometimes it makes sense
because you know humans they do not
belong to they eating how do you call it
ecosystem card ecosystem yes beautiful
planet without the human experiment yeah
we don't do on no here naturally and
like wait till we get evicted I don't
know I'm just very curious about that
and also I've heard I was listening to
brunette brown you know psychologists
neuroscientist she's awesome and she's
very well respected so her staff when
she talks about something it's it's it's
real people like I think she has
influence on people and this good and
she was talking about this
dehumanization process when we
dehumanize a person we can do anything
to this person anything and that's why
when we use the humanization words like
calling people animal names it means
that we are not considering than people
and it gives us psychological right to
diminish them to put them down to relate
to that because human to human humans
and harm other humans it's just not
biologically possible but when the
humanization happens we can that's right
that's right so this is interesting that
the basis of our existence is
dehumanization like this is I don't I
loved apes and monkeys no animal world
is beautiful but you know this causality
is that we evolved from monkeys I'm
always crashing them because I have
never seen like half monkey half person
why this process stopped why like some
portion of monkeys or Apes they
evolutionized
and why we don't see right now any
species who would be in this process
yeah there's there's there's a couple
things that you brought up there that
are very interesting to point out well
one of the things that you brought up is
this this constant curiosity for truth
period no matter what no matter for
different for different narratives for
variety of opinions and this is this is
very important because you you do want
to be at the at the truth no matter what
it is and sometimes different stories
can be put in place due to greed or
corruption or money or whatever it may
be and so just a this is just to explain
it's it's very difficult for humans to
try and take themselves out of their 25
or 50 or 75 year lifespan into a million
year lifespan this is very difficult for
humans to wrap their mind around so when
you when you see the oldest texts and
the oldest pieces of art that we have
from thousands and tens of thousands of
years ago those are the those are the
closest things we have on ajust a 10,000
year level to what had happened over
hundreds of thousands and millions of
years prior to that
so the artifacts are gone which is
making this very difficult process of by
figuring out who we are and how we got
here
but humans struggle so much with taking
themselves out of their 25 50 75 years
lifespan into the past and into
evolution and being able to understand
that process now whether it's panspermia
or whether it be evolutionary here on
earth just over several billions of
years it's a it's a very exciting
thought experiment to be able to aim to
wrap one's mind into and around and then
you know you bring you bring that up
that's really interesting you bring up
how Russia has their own conspiracies
which is about the unique every country
every country does period but there is
something really interesting about you
know ron was mentioning this too just
that a lot of the time we may think that
we are doing something with the best
positive intention but we may actually
be causing more turmoil or more
disruption in other parts of the world
that may have harmoniously just came to
their own sort of equilibrium and their
own philosophies and whatnot so okay but
wrapping this all the way into your you
know these these neuroscience
recommendations that you're passing the
people we've started the some false
memories yeah and false memories is so
fascinating because we change as you
said every time we recall we change 10%
when I think about it that way I for
myself I even go and realize how many
times I go back and I'm like was it like
that how was it and how was it exactly
it's so hard we can until we actually
have the faculties like brain computer
interfaces and whatnot to actually be
able to retrieve retrieve yeah yeah
that's yeah nice yeah you know there are
other all this futuristic movies where
there are devices that retrieve memory
every time when you can just go back
like searching your laptop yeah but also
you know all for example me military
people some of them are forced to read
video diaries every day they video
record themselves talking out loud what
happened and it's because you know there
is a proof yeah and this is the first
time they recall information so this is
the least likelihood that it will be
changed dramatically corrupted yeah I
see this is the goal of those this is
like that camera that some police
officers are wearing now so yeah I've
never seen that the the video that they
capture every single day is that is the
memory instead of what humans try to
recall we have now have it on a video
camera on the front-facing part of that
just like this conversation we're having
right now yeah
if this wasn't videotaped tomorrow we
could to be like remember when you
talked about this and you know sometimes
sometimes when I finding myself like
arguing with somebody if something
happened or not I mean not in terms of
history or something but just something
that yesterday happened and when I
feeling that I'm not finding the same
like the same answer in the purse I'm
just you know false memories exist there
is like two orphans either you write
either I write or like there is a third
chance always that's something in the
middle happens so there is no point of
our game if you have a memory and you
believe in it there is no other person
that can you know convince the other way
so it's just well there are some that
are very important like if if we were
hanging out yesterday and we went and we
were walking down Market Street and did
we see a fire truck yeah we're not
whatever-whatever not really a big deal
if you say yes and I say no yeah but if
we're talking like a year ago did you
say something to me that caused me to
have trauma yeah and then I and then you
say no i dint and I say yes you did
that can be a big tension point in a
relationship and something like that
so okay interesting these memory recalls
okay so now what are more of these yet
these cognitive neuroscience traits that
we can implement into the the dream
sprint that you're doing yeah yeah yeah
so of course it's uh it's a little bit
of a secret process yeah I can just map
map everything because I really want to
have this a surprise element yes because
when you anticipate something there is
different perception and for example
actually the trim spread started this
Saturday yep and I have 95 participants
95 yeah that's awesome
yeah because first 10 days are free like
completely free and you can get like
really really good value from even
following this for for ten days but the
whole thing is surrounded like 3035 days
and every three days there is a new
challenge and I'm really like I'm really
a little bit scared to come back today
to my apartment because I have have a
second phone for that like second second
device yes and today and tomorrow is the
deadline so I bet how many ninety-five
check yeah today so it will be quite a
ride but I already got so many kind of
like assignments done yesterday that
were people just were like so excited to
do that because finally they got to do
something and we have the deadline it
kind of like makes they do this thing
and then they feel good about themselves
yes yes that's right this is the this
interesting human nature that until we
are forced to do something we actually
tend to like postpone things totally and
it's totally normal don't like postpone
things forever yeah yeah sometimes
sometimes something lies in the forever
bucket that's the procrastination yeah
yeah but you you really want to push
people out of the forever bucket for
their most important dreams don't put
those in the forever postponing bucket
how do you make the actionable items to
get to your main dream you're maybe
yeah your main thing yeah I said that's
very interesting you're so with 95 then
people it's cool because you get to see
them complete these it's like a
psychological experiment you know some
people for example I just did this set
of photo messages and just roll down an
assignment and a couple of people teat
them like in three hours and they were
like they take a couple of hours to do
so some people just do something right
away
I bet 95% of people we do it like 30
minutes before the dime of the deadline
me too actually me too I've enjoyed this
overtime and it's also like how much you
really want to do this thing yes if your
activities are really interesting I'm
gonna do them right away yeah yeah but
the deadline is still you know it's
still like yeah two days away so I think
I just did so I'm really curious how
these thirst things goes because I bet
every single challenge will cut off some
people and I'm totally prepared for that
too so they find like my projections
maybe like 15 people will go to the end
yep that's probably about right yeah
somewhere around like 15 percent of
people look around yeah yeah cuz it's
really tough for people to hold
themselves accountable for self growth
for looking at my soul not that they
accountable in front of like me and the
fact that they pay money on dates have
yeah and if you you know just paid money
and didn't do the thing you just delete
it in your waste it's a huge psychology
experiment like you're saying and you
get to see how people grow over a thirty
five day period with these skills so
then you're constantly researching new
ones as well these new recommendations
to send them again and maybe the next
month if you do this again the dream
sprint in the spring and the summer it's
the same thing but then you then you can
do it on your own yeah but then you can
come up with new activities as well yeah
I don't plant it I plan really narrow
this down one time yeah you did one time
it's real it's literally this process
it's so it's not just random things yes
yes one assignment after another it's
like very very logical you can't change
something because it won't it won't be
cohesive in an order it has to be done
in the order because it helps you to
narrow down things that you really want
because one thing with dreams that
dreams come true only if we truly want
them because sometimes it's so weird we
want things in the middle and what I
mean by things in the middle for example
a friend of mine I know he really wants
to be like a successful entrepreneur he
really wants this he really wants one
watcher preneur instead of Auto key
success he's a successful emergency
because it's a funny yeah aspire
interpret no he's not in the spy
entrepreneur he is like real
enterpreneur and he says that all I want
to be accessible to preneur but actually
his personality is not for
entrepreneurship directly so although he
wants it he doesn't enjoy being this but
what he really wants he wants the
freedom to travel the world at any like
expanse that he you know can think about
so basically he wants yeah interesting
to get to that the money to travel and
yeah do something to get to that end
goal yes and the Entrepreneurship is one
of the things because we're in San
Francisco if you were in Moscow you
would go work for government to have
money in San Francisco it's cool to be a
startup person it's cool to you know do
the VC game and it's also kind of like a
social pressure that's like all of those
social pressures all of those different
circumstances in our life
they prevent us of pointing the final
thing only or even acknowledging that we
wanted so I have several things that he
feels yeah like what do you really want
like do one to be a successful pro why
because then you got to his end goal
which was to be able to travel and
experience things so you got a like you
said what do you really want so you got
to get to the end and then you have done
what are your short-term steps to get to
that end because you like you said in
different parts of the world you would
pursue it differently VC government
whatever yeah alright yeah so this is
this is the major thing that I found
that why people don't have their dreams
like come true because they they want
something they don't want this is the
when you know like our brains are not
designed to have a conflict when we have
a conflict like I'm selecting
information our brain our brain just
they don't care about this no I'm not
working on that you better decide what's
the priority and then I'm working on
that because it's also like this like we
hear everywhere about clear intention
should be clear your attention like
transplants always test cells that clear
intention with positive emotion creates
this and that but then you hear that L
for example for me it didn't plant like
right away as a clear and Jessica I have
a clear intention I have it but I didn't
you know I wanted this like middle goals
and the beauty of dreams rather than
goal setting and goal setting always
love goal setting but goal setting is
rather like what I need to do and dreams
are like what I want so this is this
subtle difference between goals and
dreams
so dreams has this like Airy space
within them that can align circumstances
in billions of different ways to bring
you from point A to this clear intention
within your dream you know and for goals
you create steps yourself for dreams you
are not who creates the steps you are
not consciously creating the steps does
this does this does it wherever this
idea or this dream this long term comes
from through us and then we're not the
subconscious takes over for the
short-term goals to get to this
long-term dream or idea dreams can be
not long-term dreams can be very short
jump for example a great example of
dreams can be small you know so we have
behavior hero this message is dream big
if you dream about something give us
something big but actually it's not
those dreams you can't you know in order
to build this muscle of getting in tune
with your dreams you should dream small
because sometimes he wants and buy small
things I mean for example um like you
want to meet this and that person I
don't know celebrity crush whatever and
it's not a goal where you can Oh first I
do this and this for this thing
circumstances should align and however
hard you try it's not the thing for
which you try hard
it's thing that either happens or not
and you're not the one who builds you
know they deal set of steps to to
manifest it yeah so whether it's
short-term or long-term dream you're not
building the steps to manifest it it's
coming through you it's it's more it's
more I mean it's more practical in terms
of
every every every single day we make
like thirty thousand decisions yeah it's
a lot of decisions a lot of decisions
and you know and how many of those are
we consciously made you yeah we are we
are consciously making like a tiny a
tiny bit of those but all of those all
of these decisions that we make kind of
like unconsciously not even subconscious
is just like unconsciously automatically
our brains has already its programs to
the side and our brain has a destination
way it goes and you either aware about
that destination are either not God this
is a whole nother episode of
conversation this last part is so
interesting so there's an autumn there's
an autonomic nervous system that's doing
the heartbeats and the eye blinks and
cetera and their regulations regulation
this homeostatic capacity etc and then
and then there's there's the unders that
this unconscious further with even with
our dream and our the short-term this
long-term these steps along the way
sometimes yeah I guess where did this
where did this I guess where did the
show and where did your speaking and
well-being advocating come from did it
come from somewhere else through you and
I just had clear intention I really know
that I wanted I really knew that I
wanted I did the process and if it come
from before you knew that you wanted it
before I knew that you wanted
oh I always loved to be on stage I
hosted like events for like 3,000 people
in Moscow and like one of the largest
venues in in Moscow and I really enjoyed
it and when I came here in the United
States I was like oh my god I'm not a
native English speaker but all my kind
of like good you know all my career was
based on basically speaking and working
with information communicating with
people in Russian language that's what I
did and then I came here was just what
should I do like it was it was totally
devastating for me
because everything that I was proud of
myself everything that gave me power you
know everything that I was believing in
it was kind of like taken away by by
myself it was taken away and I was I was
so diverse l just I'm not a native
speaker like so many people who can do
it better you know all this stuff I was
kind of like talking myself out and it's
very interesting when we talk ourself
out of something this is very
interesting narrative which is very very
curious some of the exercises is like
about like deconstructing those
narratives yeah how we reason something
for example I don't I don't know what
would be like a suitable example if I
asked you I don't know what are your
dreams so there because dreams but if I
ask something and then ask you like
what's the reason why now what's the
reason why you don't think it's even
like in a year and then just a little
and I was doing this to myself just oh
this is this is no this is not this is
yeah this is totally true because this
is true this is like the most objective
truth in the world instead of taking
your time to more slowly process and try
and think things through on a
multi-variant basis I still if if
civilization didn't have this unique
social fabric around it that pressured
you to pursue the you know brainpower
speaker and yeah well I'm well being
advocate like if we already knew what we
needed to know about our brain power if
we knew where we needed to about well be
you would be doing some other idea that
yeah if we already had like 100% these
shows and everything I would be doing
something else been so so these things
come in weird ways through us I'm still
so fascinated by what happens at the
when you started saying I keep feeling
like oh I'm in some somewhat control
over the you know my own ways of
behaving with my short-term goals but
you're like yeah now you're just you
know there's this whole conversation
about for your will this whole
conversation about about a goal
execution and how we actually get there
hold
time to talk about us I'm excited for
your class the dream sprint I'm excited
for this and for everyone they can check
it out in the links below and arias
website two quick questions on the way
out okay and we'll have to talk more
about the dream sprint when you come
back so we can unpack these 12 birdies
it's 95 people those people who 95 I'm
really excited for those who will go til
the end there's gonna be 12 total
lessons right fish yes yes every three
days for 30 days so about 12 total
lessons 95 people ish however many stay
with you so we can unpack this and like
yeah yeah yeah and unpack the lessons
and the results the two quick questions
do you think we're in a simulation
it's hard it's hard I don't think so I
don't think so
why it's just how do we define
simulation how do you define it
simulation for me something like
artificial imposed but for example if we
are talking about our senses and for
example dr. David Eagleman he talks
about like human own well that we are
perceiving only a small percentage but
it doesn't mean that we're in simulation
it means that we are not perceiving
what's out there we don't have enough
tools to perceive it so I rather believe
in that that we just don't have enough
you know skillset tools biological
devices to do that but everything is out
there you know yep and then the last
question what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world
waterfall this is just came to my mind
just random literal like right away when
you said it tell us why maybe it's
because I've been to Iceland this summer
and I've seen this waterfall and when
the rainbow kind of like cross through
waterfall and it was kind of like
flowing rainbow it was very very
beautiful yeah mother earth has some
gorgeous attributes like that
yeah Daria this has been such a pleasure
likewise thank you thank you for this
isn't such a pleasure there's so much to
still understand about how to actually
manifest these dreams using these
techniques of neuroscience of
understanding our minds and
understanding how to set these
intentions and these dreams everyone go
and check out Daria links below thank
you so much for tuning and we greatly
appreciate it love to hear your thoughts
in the comments below also go and embark
on your own dream sprint whether it be
with Dario with yourself set these
actionable items and go and get your
dreams manifested into the world thanks
Ron for producing and directing support
your artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe in everyone we love you so much
and we will see you soon
peace
[Applause]
[Music]